i've been almost for united states i
never got my travel license
the only uses was was like tati's
oh chantelle driving around all the time
so i know the this is going to make her
so happy
let me lock the dog i said i want to
fall out okay so here we go
hold on for a second so we just don't
want to use the horn
okay
pedro are you with me yeah so let's put
it in drive
now i'm going to the road yes
ah to the road yes you'll be fine
here we go
no we don't honk at people just because
they're
okay good at the stop we're gonna make a
right turn that's a little fast
okay all right so now
we're gonna keep straight in this lane
okay so we don't we don't want to do
that and then you jerk the wheel
did you feel it was a little sharp okay
so we're just gonna kind of tap on the
gas a little bit
there we go okay is your foot on the
brake this is a green light
this is a green light this is a green
light this is a green light
okay no this is a green light okay so
let's just go ahead and give it some gas
okay there we go okay thank you there we
go
okay
if i had to rate pedro on a scale from
zero to ten
he's a three
[Music]
you